hey youtubers is Charlie hopefully you
guys have had a chance to see Doctor Who
episode eight so we got to see Fox's
guest star along with a big British
comedian and the whole Clara situation
was explained the way things ended were
a little controversial I think but we
can talk about that as we dig through
everything and just a reminder the
giveaway is regenerating this week all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and just leave a comment on
this video real simple so here we go
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet okay here we go
number 5 Fox's is a lounge singer on the
train I'm not a huge Fox's fan or
anything but I did love that she was
seeing Freddie Mercury to be specific it
was Queens don't stop me now very
appropriate for a story to set on a
train even though it wasn't really a
train story at the end of the day I feel
like every time we see a new famous
person on Doctor Who the conversation
becomes they're using too many famous
people but they've used a lot of pop
stars in the past so it doesn't bother
me that much I feel like it helped a lot
that she was seeing Freddie Mercury and
not one of her own songs she wasn't
really in the episode that long she
ended up being one of the hologram so
she did vanish part of the way through
so if you didn't like her she was gone
pretty quickly
number four Frank Skinner is the
engineer this was a bit of a twist in
real life for anyone who doesn't know
Skinner's a comedian but he wasn't
playing an overtly comedic role in the
episode he's actually been on Doctor Who
before if you watched the five ish
doctors special during the 50th
anniversary he had a cameo in that as a
Dalek operator I do really like it when
comedians are given the chance to do
something more dramatic everyone totally
needs to watch Eddie Izzard on Hannibal
season 1 if you haven't seen it yet he
plays this creepy serial killer and it's
totally terrifying
there's something about comedians that I
find inherently dark maybe that's why
they're so good at playing dramatic
characters but that's just my opinion I
think Skinner's first run-in with the
doctor was probably one of the funniest
parts of the episode though he didn't
seem like he was able to match the
doctors wits and he even knew how to
repair the TARDIS although I feel like
that's kind of controversial I guess
there are other races that have
knowledge of Time Lord technology but to
be able to actively fix a TARDIS
requires real genius that bit at the end
with him raised so many questions I
thought it was interesting that the
doctor extended the invitation to board
the TARDIS permanently or
semi-permanently
in context though I think it was just a
conceit of the clerestory they were just
playing with the idea that a new
companion would come on although if they
did bring a new companion on it would
probably be someone younger I know a lot
of you guys actually want to see a male
companion again it's possible that they
could do that in series 9 or 10
depending on whatever Jenna Coleman
leaves
I actually thought Danny pink was gonna
be one of the permanent companions until
the Clara romance thing was explained
let me know though if we do get a male
companion would you care how old he is
like would you rather he be someone
younger like Danny pink or do you just
not care at all number three the doctor
lies does anyone else feel like the
doctor was off his rocker just a little
bit during the episode like lying is a
totally normal thing and to be expected
but the whole bit with Clara trying to
rope in that next woman that was gonna
die was really extreme his line was so
dark though I don't care what you tell
her just lie and tell her I'll save her
anything to get her here that feels cold
even for the doctor even though he did
mess with her head later and took her
place
it didn't seem completely genuine it was
like he only did that to calm Clara down
his explanation at the end wasn't much
comfort either it was like he was
telling Cara that she should just
believe whatever she wants to believe to
make her happiest like he's dodging the
question about whether or not he's a
good person it's a bit of a cop-out on
his part and I think that kind of thing
is gonna haunt him in the finale
number two the mummy is an ancient
soldier I totally love the big callbacks
to empty child with the are you my mummy
and the gas mask shout out the final
solution to the problem felt a little
bit rushed in the end but I guess the
whole conceit of 66 seconds makes a
little bit of sense in the context of
the story so I'll give it a pass there
are other things in the episode that you
can complain about more right now I'm
actually wondering what the war was that
that soldier was a part of essentially
he was tied to that scroll or flag or
however we want to think about it and
the only reason he continued to drain
energy from people was because the
device inside him that helped repair his
body was malfunctioning I think it's a
really interesting metaphor for the
doctor the soldier clearly a monster
just like the doctor was for most of the
episode wanted to die but could not it's
almost like they're saying that the
doctor has been sucking the life out of
Clara to keep himself going I mean
that's not the case I don't think that's
what they were trying to say but I feel
like it's in the subtext
in reality I think it's just
foreshadowing for the finale for other
characters there have been some liberal
spoilers about the finale so if you've
seen those please just use spoiler tags
if you're gonna comment on them see if
you can connect these things though dead
soldiers unable to stop forced to keep
fighting and think about which other new
character on the show everyone is
calling the soldier again even if you're
just theory crafting please use spoiler
tags and my number one WTF moment Clara
totally changes her mind I didn't pick
this to be my number one just because I
think it's awesome I think it's a major
holy crap moment like I actually don't
think it's a hopeful thing I think this
is bad something about the whole scene
felt really ominous it's like Clara
should have learned her lesson but going
against Danny's better judgment she's
gonna get smacked in the face with some
terrible situation it's almost like she
wasn't even listening to the doctor
whenever she woke up on that planet he
was trying to tell her that he only
intended to save her like he only cared
about her all those other people just
happened to come along for the ride I
mean he wasn't purposefully gonna let
them die but if they had he wouldn't
really cared that much it's like it was
supposed to be a Butch Cassidy Sundance
kids story where they jump off like a
giant cliff at the end but I feel like
it was almost too easy for the doctor to
come up with his solution like yes I
mean he did have 60 seconds to live but
who knows what would have happened if
the soldiers started sucking life out of
him the interesting thing about that is
that I don't think even the doctor knows
what would happen if he started getting
the life force sucked out of him let me
know though what was your favorite
moment and do you think that Clara made
the right choice or something completely
terrible going to happen to her because
she stayed with the doctor overall I
gave the episode a solid B I love the
story concept ancient soldier forced to
continue fighting a war that ended
thousands of years ago the original
Orient Express ran during the late
Victorian era which is why everyone
looked like they were back in Victorian
times I know a lot of you guys aren't
big fans of them going back to Victorian
times all the time on the show I do
wonder if there's any special
significance to them doing that so much
it's totally possible that it's just
because the producers and the set
designers think that that's just an
interesting period visually I mean I do
really enjoy the visual style of the
Victorian era so I'm not gonna complain
about that too much the only big downer
for me was when they kind of through the
mythology
story line out and ended up being this
sciency episode I'm not sure why they
decided to go with the evil scientist
aspect unless it has some sort of
meaning for the finale or their
foreshadowing something we aren't down
to the last three episodes I'm just
counting the last two is a two-parter
even though I think the Christmas
special is probably gonna address a few
things from the finale just in general I
am a fan of the passenger train setting
for stories like this I mean usually
it's done in Wild West stories but Star
Trek did their own Orient Express
episode and they've done a lot of
Sherlock stuff too with the holodeck you
guys can let me know whether or not you
would have just enjoyed it being a mummy
story whether or not you thought it had
to be you know really science II lots
other stuff going on this weekend though
I will be doing the Q&A tomorrow but
Walking Dead Season 5 is starting so
I'll be doing a couple videos for that
after about the middle of the day
so be sure to check out that episode
people in the UK you should be able to
watch The Walking Dead episode by Monday
I think it's like 9 o'clock which is I
think within like eight hours of people
in the US so you don't have to wait that
long
right now though click here to get the
Q&A I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post it tomorrow and click here for my
episode 7 video thank you so much for
watching so let's all high-five I'll see
you guys tomorrow
you